you know this whole thing with the the
the the great uh Greta Thunder you know
yeah
she's apparently getting an Oscar and
do this real quick and look at how fun
she's having look hey okay let's let's
act like I'm getting arrested yeah hold
on wait look is that dirt on his face on
purpose look he put coal on it
she looks frightened right now you see
that there's your chapped lips get it
okay ready other camera guy make sure
the lighting noise wet look it that's
they're gripping her really hard yeah
she looks like Nike she looks like she
has a lot of solutions
you know yeah but but you know what the
the fact that this is effective people
fall before and she's got six million
Twitter followers oh yeah pause it go to
the meme that uh the the meme I just
texted you you'll see it's not online
the fact that this video is out we all
see it's circulating people it won't
even budge anybody the real people that
believe in they're like what do you mean
she was just waiting no I think it would
I don't I don't know I think so I bro
dude that thing got 12 million views
that clip got 12 million now watch this
here this is the Still In My Dreams yeah
and my channel
that's the best me my best is that not
the best well that's what that's what
she doesn't understand that's what she
doesn't understand you know and my thing
is that you can Scream and Shout they
can have these theatrical meetings and
things at Davos but at the end of the
day economies are going to do what
economies do and you know I don't that
we don't have right now an alternative
so sorry yeah you mean alternative to
what exactly green green is not here
alternative I mean if you talk to people
that really follow this stuff and get
into the minutia you don't want coal
really okay give me are we gonna burn
wood just tell me what we're supposed to
do yeah tell people to stop tell here's
the biggest thing the developing world
is not going to stop being poor because
you want to save trees that's the truth
they they want to keep they want to get
out of their situation you know it's
like um somebody in in uh who was it
Warren Buffett's grandson or son Warren
Buffett Warren Buffett gave his son a
million dollars a billion dollars a
billion and said go change the world and
his his son was uh a farmer so he went
to the Congo
and uh and he tried to and I had him on
the podcast he tried to kind of like
teach them farming practices but the
Congo had been ravaged by Civil War of
course as We Know and the guy said to
him he said you know and then they were
trying to save gorillas and stuff and
the guy goes my family's not going to
starve for a gorilla and it sure as heck
isn't going to starve for a tree that's
just the way it is you're not going to
stop human beings from trying to get out
of their shitty situation and you know
so I think the only way to get out of
this is to innovate our way out of it
Innovation is always the way I don't I
just don't I just don't think that you
know you have to have some legislation
of course you have to have some you know
regulation but come on man at the end of
the day it's not going to get us out of
this game so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]